Okay, so I'm beginning on June the 4th 1916. This is volume 11.
Jesus pours out his bitterness into Louisa, so to spare the people.
But it's too much for her to contain it all. So Louisa says this morning it seemed that my
beloved Jesus came. I plastered him to my heart and Jesus gave me a kiss. But as he was kissing me,
I felt a most bitter liquid flow from his mouth to mine. I remained surprised in seeing that
without praying him, sweet Jesus was pouring his bitterness into me. While at other times,
I had prayed him so much that he, but he had not conceded it to me.
A thought has occurred to me that I've forgotten to give you in all the other
reflections that I've given to you. And that is that Saint Bernard of Clairville, 12th century,
he's called the on-ground king of the 12th century, wrote at least two or if not three volumes of
commentary on the song of songs. And he gave, as far as I can remember, about eight sermons
on the first line, let him kiss me with the kisses of his mouth. How do you give eight sermons
about 20 minutes long each on that thing? And the thing I remember, that he said, out of all the
homilies, he said, don't think it is a romantic thing to give Jesus a kiss. That's what I'm reminded
of now, because he said on his lips, there's vinegar and gall and bitterness. And if you approach
him at that level, that's what the only thing he can share with you. It's not romance. That's why
we're inclined to think of a kiss simply as a romantic sign or an affectionate sign. But with
Jesus, it's not that. And so that's why Louisa said, I didn't even ask. And this time he gave me
the bitterness that was within him. Okay. So then she said, I was filled with that most bitter liquid,
but Jesus kept pouring. It's spilled outside. Now it's spilled outside means that Louisa is not
able to make reparation for all the sin that's going on in the world. So there will be chastisement.
It's spilled outside. It went to the ground, but he's still kept pouring. So he was trying to indicate
to her how deep the problems of the earth were at this particular time. So that there was a pool
of that most bitter liquid formed around me and blessed Jesus. And then as though relieved a little,
now you understand a little because a lot of this has poured out onto the ground. He told me,
daughter, have you seen how much bitterness souls give me? It is so much that unable to
contain them any longer. I wanted to pour them into you. And she's always asking for this. But
you couldn't contain them either. So they went to the ground and they will pour upon the peoples.
Okay. In other words, if I can't contain them and you can't contain them, they've got to go back
on the people. So remember, I said to you from the early volumes, the sin goes up from the earth
and comes back right as chastisements. In other words, we create chastisement. It's something we do
ourselves because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God. That's Hebrews 1214.
So while seeing this, he marked the various points and towns which were to be stricken by
the invasions of foreign people. Now that sounds as if you're talking about the invasion of Italy
during the World Wars. And some were running away and some were left naked and starved,
some were exiled, some killed, horror and fright everywhere. Jesus himself wanted to withdraw his
gaze from so much tragedy. Frightened and terrorized, I wanted to prevent Jesus from doing this,
but he seemed unshakable and he told me, my daughter, it is their own bitterness that divine
justice is pouring upon the people. That's what I said. We actually create the chastisement. So I
want to give you two Corinthians nine six, two Corinthians nine six and Galatians six seven to eight.
So we even use this in our everyday language. We say that person is their own worst enemy.
Is that right? Yeah. Or we say, should they create their own troubles?
So Louisa said, oh, sorry, Jesus said, I wanted to pour them in you first in order to spare some
points and to make you content because she's always asking for this. And what was left I would
pour upon them my justice demands satisfaction. See, all the attributes of God are equal.
And we seem to think that if his justice doesn't work, that he's happier and we're happier. But
just as every part of your being needs expression, so every part of his being needs expression as well.
So Louisa said, my love and my life, I know little about justice, she said, if I pray you,
it is for mercy, because that's her role as intercessor. I make appeal to your love, to your wounds,
and to your blood. After all, there are always your they are always your children, your dear images.
Okay. So the images are Romans eight. And I think it's 29. Okay.
Poor brothers of mine, how shall they go on into what constraints shall they be put to make me
content? You tell me that you have poured into me, but some points are too few. But the points
you spare are too few. Now what she's doing is something that had gone on since the time of Abraham.
Do you remember Abraham interceding for Sodom and Gomorrah in Genesis 1832? You know, if I can get
down from 50 to 45 to 40, and he goes down all the way to five, but there weren't five decent men
in the town. Then you have Moses, which is Sam 106 verse 23. He stood in the breach. Otherwise,
they would all have been killed. You also have Ezekiel 22 30. And Isaiah 59 verses 15 to 16.
That gives you a way of looking at the intercessor's role. So the two new ones there are Ezekiel 22
30 and Isaiah 59 verses 15 and 16. Now anyone who's called to be a victim, soul is called to be an
intercessor. So they always plead for the souls of the people. And they're prepared to pay a price
for it as well. So Jesus said, on the contrary, he said, and Louisa said it was too little,
and he said, no, it's too much. It's because I love you. Otherwise, I would have spared nothing.
Now the thing that's very important there is the value God puts on one person. Louisa is only one
person out of the whole planet. And she is making this request of God. And God hears her because he
loves her in a special way. That's terribly important for anyone living in the divine will.
You're in a special relationship with God. Therefore he will hear you in a special way.
And besides, have you not seen how you yourself were unable to contain anymore?
So Louisa burst out crying and said, yet you tell me that you love me. And where is all this love
that you have for me? Now, what she's doing is using this love as a lever to see can she get more
mercy for the people. That's her intercessory role. True love knows how to content the beloved
in everything. And then why don't you make me larger, she said, so that I can contain more
bitterness, despair, my brothers. Jesus cried with me and disappeared. But I would imagine when
you disappeared, he smiled a little bit, make me a bit bigger and I'll be able to hold it.
Okay, most of us don't ask to be made bigger physically. Certainly not to hold bitterness
anyway, whatever else. So there's a very important message coming up in June the 15th, 1916. I have
a VIP on this one. In the divine will, everything is complete. Look at the word complete. The most
powerful prayers over the heart of Jesus and those which move him the most are to clothe oneself
with all that he himself did and suffered. Now, would you color that in green, white and gold?
I would read it again. The most powerful prayers over the heart of Jesus and those who move him the
most are to clothe oneself with all that he himself did and suffered. Okay. So continuing in my usual
state, my beloved Jesus came, he transformed me completely into him. And then he told me, daughter,
pour yourself into my will. Now we usually say fuse. Same thing. Fuse yourself into my will
in order to make complete reparations from me. Now notice complete because it will be divine
and human and it will involve all that Jesus has done. My love feels an irresistible need for them.
That's for reparations. And so after so many offenses from souls, it wants one at least who
placing herself between me and them. There's the intercessor standing in the breach. And that's
your Sam 106 verse 23 again. Moses standing in the breach. So placing herself between me and them
would give me complete reparation. You don't need the S in English. It would give me complete love
for all and would snatch from me graces for everyone. You hear Louisa doing that all the time.
But you can only do this in my will. Now we just circle the word only. It can't be done outside of
fusing in the divine will. In other words, you can say the words, but it's not it's not the action.
Is that okay? This miracle only happens when we're fused in the divine will in which you find me
and you also find all souls. That's where we connect with all souls. Oh, with what yearnings
am I waiting for you to enter into my will? That's diffuse. To be able to find in you the
satisfaction and the reparation for all. Now the two S's are not required there. Only in my will
will you find the things in act. That means present now available graceful and grace filled
because anything to do with God is now. There's no past. There's no future. Everything is now.
Because I am the engine, the actor and the spectator of everything. I love the engine.
The church usually says that God is the prime mover. That's the engine that moves it forward.
So while he was saying this, Louisa said, I poured myself into his will. But who can say what I saw,
I was in contact with every thought of every person. Look at that. This is how to influence
people from within, from their deepest soul. I was in contact with the life which came from God
and I in his will multiplied myself in each thought. And with the sanctity of his will,
I repaired everything. Do you see the power we have once refused in the divine will?
I had a thank you for everyone and a love for everyone also. Then I multiplied myself in the
gazes, in the words and in everything else. So here's a perfect way to pray and intercede for others.
But who can say all that was happening? I lack the terms and maybe the very angelic tongues would
stammer and therefore I stop here. That's one of the problems that anybody receiving a message from
God has. And I put one Corinthians two nine there that the eye cannot perceive and the ear cannot
get it. All that God has prepared for us. And the problem is that she receives it in a purely
spiritual manner on a spiritual plane, which is trying to communicate it on a human plane
and to translate that language down into the human plane, she feels she can't do it because
he's going to lose so much. Now all the saints have had that problem. So Louisa said I spent
the whole night with Jesus in his will. It's not a lovely way to spend your night. And then I felt
the queen mother near me and she told me she's never far away if he's around. She told me my daughter
pray. Now she's been saying that for how many years? 35 years is in Magigori. And Louisa said
my mother let us pray together. I think that's brilliant. For by myself I don't know how to pray.
And she added now this is her message to us. The most powerful prayers over the heart of my son
and those which move him the most are for the soul to clothe herself with everything he did
and suffered. Can't you see that she's repeating what Jesus said? Okay she's underlining it.
Since he gave everything as a gift to the soul, now I prefer the word soul to creature
because creatures include animals. Okay and so the translator obviously wasn't thinking about the
fact that creatures include animals. Therefore my daughter in surround your head with the thorns of
Jesus, bead your eyes with his tears, impregnate your tongue with his bitterness, clothe your soul
with his blood, adorn yourself with his wounds, pierce your hands and feet with his nails and like
another Christ present yourself before the divine majesty. Now that way of praying you are reading
in the hours of the Passion because you hear Louisa actually praying that way. Okay so this site
blessed mother said will move him in such a way that he will not be able to deny anything to the soul
who is clothed in his own insignia. Isn't that something? Now how terribly important that is
when we go to pray for family and friends and absolutely everybody to know how to pray for them
with authority and power that will have real effects. But how little do souls know how to make
use of the gifts which my son gave them? Now the souls that don't make use of the gifts are
Catholics who are not really using the treasures of their faith. These were my prayers on earth. Now
that's the important thing there. In other words she's saying how she prayed and these are my prayers
in heaven. That means you have the prayers of the chorodemptrix and therefore if we pray that way
we're praying with the the redeemer and the chorodemptrix. That's power. So together
Louisa and blessed mother cloted themselves with the insignia of Jesus and together
they presented themselves before the divine throne. Isn't that absolutely beautiful?
But you present yourself with blessed mother. This moved all, that means all the inhabitants
of heaven. The angels made way for us and remained as those surprised. The surprise was to see somebody
from the earth. They wouldn't be surprised or blessed lady. I thanked mother and I found myself
inside of myself. Now that's something you've got to go back on and learn how to use.
So August the third 1916. Each act of the soul that the soul does is one more paradise that she
acquires in heaven. Louisa said as I continuing in my usual state my beloved Jesus makes himself
seen in passing or he says a few words and then runs away or he hides in my interior.
Now hides in my interior is Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you and I remember
that one day he told me my daughter I am the center and all creation receives life from this
center. That's John 14 6 I am the way the truth and the life. So I am the life of every thought,
of every word, of every action, of everything. But souls make use of this life. I give them
to take the occasion to offend me. I give life and if they could they would give me death which
of course is exactly what happened in the Passion isn't it? Louisa says I also remember that I prayed
him to hold back the scourges and he told me daughter do you think I am the one who wants to
scourge them? No on the contrary my love is so great that I consumed my whole life in redoing
what man was obliged to do. This is your divine version okay. So I consumed my whole life in redoing
what man was obliged to do for the supreme majesty and since my acts were divine I multiplied them
into into so many as to redo them for all humanity and for each soul. In such a way as to fill heaven
and earth and to keep man defended so that justice might not strike them. But man with sin breaks this
defense. Now notice that the Lord has done everything he could to defend us and we break the defense
and once the defense is broken the scourge is strike man. So I want to give you some scriptures
which explain what happens when you have no shield and you have no defense. Is that okay?
I want to go and give you some of them. There's loads of them. Genesis 15.1. Sam 3.3.
Sam 5.20. Sam 28.7. Sam 33.20.
Now in Genesis 15 the Lord says I am your encircling shield. In other words you are protected back
and front because in those days it was single combat is the way they fought battles. An encircling
shield wouldn't be any use if you have a bomb coming down on top of your head. So you have to
just understand the context in which it is given. So if we drop that shield or let it go in any way
then that protection is gone. We're open to the enemy. But who can say all the little things he
told me? Then this morning I was praying and lamenting to Jesus for he was not answering me.
Notice she expects to be answered especially because he does not stop chastising and I said to him
why pray to you if you do not want to answer me? On the contrary you tell me that the evils will
get worse. Now that's Amos 3.7 that he always tells the prophets ahead of time.
And Jesus' answer was my daughter good is always good. Even more you must know that each prayer,
each reparation, each act of love, any holy thing that the soul does is one more paradise
that she acquires. Really take note of that will you? Each act, each prayer, each reparation,
each holy thing. Now even a holy thing. Isn't that fantastic? Look how good he is.
It's one more paradise that she acquires. So the simplest holy act will be one more
paradise. The simplest holy act. And there you are trying to remain fused in him so that acts
are being multiplied to infinity. Try and imagine the paradise is going to give you. Isn't it incredible?
So in fact every good act comes from God and therefore in every good act the soul takes God.
I like that. I don't know about you. So I put a ring around it. The soul takes God. Take possession
of him. And since God contains infinite innumerable eternal immense joys so many that the very blessed
will not arrive at enjoying them all throughout all eternity. Now I have only one comment there.
Wow. That it'll take all of heaven to try and grasp what God is actually offering you. So you
won't be bored. I remember a class of teenagers telling me that they're awfully bored in heaven
because they'll be sitting there playing harps for all eternity. And at least there'll be something
going on in hell. It's very interesting. So that when the thing is not explained properly you get
across a terrible falsehood. So I said to them you really are going to enjoy the fire. You really
are going to enjoy the tortures aren't you? You're going to call it. You're going to ask for more.
But let's talk heaven really. Jesus says that since God contains infinite innumerable eternal
immense joys that the very blessed will not arrive at enjoying them all throughout all eternity. I
love that. It's no wonder then that since each good act acquires God God is almost bound to
substitute them with many contentments. So if the soul suffers even distractions for love of me
now you're doing your hours adoration and you find yourself distracted. Do you get upset with
yourself? Give out to the other people who are distracting you or realize I've got divine currency
here. The thing we've got to realize all the time in living the divine will that is that everything
no matter what happens to you is divine currency. Okay. So I've been offering my eyes in the divine
will that the Lord will open the eyes of the nation that they will discover God again. That's
one of the things I've been doing other things as well that's one of them and everything is
divine currency. It's fantastic, you know. So if the soul suffers even distractions for love of me
in heaven, her intelligence will have more light. That means more understanding. It's fantastic.
I will enjoy as many more paradises for as many times as she has sacrificed her intelligence.
That means instead of demanding to understand something that you offer the fact that here and
now you don't. That's not a novel way of doing it, isn't it? I think it's brilliant.
And so much more will she understand God because of that sacrifice. If she suffers coldness for love
of me, so many paradises will she enjoy of the variety of contentment that are present in my love.
If darkness, that means it feels almost like unbelief. So many more contentment in my
inaccessible light. Okay. So inaccessible light is one Timothy six, 16. God lives in unapproachable
light. One Timothy six, 16. God lives in honor. That verse actually says God lives in unapproachable
light. So this is what one prayer more or less means. So I put a big N baby side that one prayer
more or less is one paradise more or less your choice. Isn't that brilliant? Okay. So August the
six, 1916, the need of Jesus for souls who live in the divine will to multiply. In other words,
other people need to come to or there's another one there as well. They need to come to enter into
the divine will because of us. Is that okay? So I have a big N B beside this and a heading which
says we need more people. So all of us have to reach out to try and help others to come into the
divine will. So as I was in my usual state, my sweet Jesus came for just a little Louisa said
and he said to me, my daughter, my love feels an irresistible need for souls to live in my will
to multiply. Therefore, we can't get off the hook. We've actually got to try and help people to come
and enter the divine will because they are the places of my quarters. Now the people who use the
term quarters are usually soldiers and people like that. So it's the place where I live is what he
wants to say. In other words, each one of us is a place where he lives. That's 1 Corinthians 3 16.
1 Corinthians 3 16. No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God. Okay.
And my love wants to do good to everyone, but sins prevent me from pouring my benefits
upon them. Therefore, I keep searching for souls in the divine will. That's these quarters. You see
the strange language. So I'm just giving you two with its meaning. I keep searching for souls in
the divine will and in them in these souls, I am not prevented from pouring my graces and through
them the towns and the people that surround them take part in them. Would you please put a huge sign
there? Name the town or the area you come from. You don't have to say it out loud. And Jesus says,
the place you live will benefit. So that means that celebrate and all its surrounds will benefit
from me living in the divine will. Sometimes I remind myself that when I'm walking down the street,
see all these people are benefiting and they don't even know. It's no wonderful.
Therefore, the more places I have to live on earth, the greater vent can I give to my love. In other
words, the more of these temples of the Holy Spirit that the Lord has that he can operate
in and through, the more he can pour out his love. Now, our country desperately needs to be
saturated with God's love and therefore people living in the divine will are the ones who can
let us happen. So the greater vent I can give to my love and the more it pours itself into
benefits for the good of all humanity. Okay. Now, I want to give you two Corinthians 2 14,
two Corinthians 2 14, where St. Paul says that we are partners of Jesus' triumph spreading
the knowledge of him everywhere, partners in his triumph. Now, that's even more important for us
than it was for Paul. When Paul was writing that, he was thinking of a triumphal procession in Rome
when the Romans really made a fuss of the general who won the battle. But as Greg says to us,
we are actually putting the red carpet together for his return. I love that image and he's really
beautiful. Okay. So we have a huge task to do. So August the 10th 1916, how in the divine will
our pains are together with those of Jesus. Now, so whatever we're suffering, physically, mentally
emotionally or spiritually, it's there, it's with Jesus and therefore has all the infinite merits
of his pains. And then we can offer them in the divine will for whoever we want.
Continuing in my usual state, I was feeling embittered because of the privation of my beloved
Jesus. And I was lamenting to him that each privation he caused me was a death that he gave me and a
cruel death, that's simply indicating the enormity of her love. Such that while one feels death, one
cannot die. And I said, how can you have the heart to give me so many deaths? And Jesus told me,
my daughter, do not lose heart. When my humanity was on earth, it contained all the lives
of creatures. And these lives came all came from me. Okay. So watch where this is going.
So he says, well, on earth, he said, his humanity contained the lives of all creatures. And how many
of them would not return to me because they would die and bury themselves in hell. Now, for him to
die actually means to go to hell, because to separate the soul from the body is not actually
the tragedy is to separate the soul from God is. And I felt the death of each one, which tormented
my humanity. Do you see where he's going with this? He's trying to tell Louisa, since you do feel
a cruel death, why don't you enter into me, fuse with me, unite with the sufferings that I had,
and you will gain many, many souls. So I want to give you Colossians one 18, Colossians one 18,
and one Corinthians 12, 12.
And Jesus continues, these debts were the most sorrowful and cruel that pain in my whole life.
That's because God is love and he didn't want to lose anyone. Up to my last breath, he said,
naturally, because in his dying, there was the thief that didn't repent. Do you remember?
My daughter, don't you want to take part in my pains? The death you feel,
the death you feel because of my privation is nothing but a shadow of the pains of death,
which I felt because of the loss of these souls. Okay, now here's the first hint. We're still in
volume 11. There's a lot to go yet. This is the first hint that Louisa is experiencing a divine
pain. It's not just human. She is permanently in the divine will, okay? And I want to give you two
Corinthians one versus six and nine. Two Corinthians one versus six and nine talking about suffering
and what to do with it. And two Corinthians four versus 16 and 17. Therefore, now that you know this,
Jesus said, give this death to me, whatever it is you're suffering, physically, mentally,
emotionally, and spiritually, give it to him, let him make divine currency out of it. Give it to me
to sweeten the many cruel deaths that my humanity suffered. Let this pain, that is of the privation,
flow in my will, whatever it is, let it flow in the divine will. And you will find mine,
that's Jesus's pain. And uniting with it, it will run for the good of all, especially for those
who are about to fall into the abyss. So Jesus is asking her, since the pain is intense,
she finds it very difficult. He's asking her to use it to save people from hell. Because as I say,
the death of the body is not actually the problem. It's the death of the soul is the problem. Now,
if you keep it for yourself, clouds will form between you and me. And you know, in clouds,
you don't really see one another. And the current of my will will be broken between you and me. Now,
why would the current be broken? Because she will be doing something that displeases him.
She's complaining instead of using divine currency. Your pains will not find mine. You will not be
able to defuse yourself for the good of all. And you will feel all the weight of it. In other words,
you'll get all of the negative side of your suffering. Whereas if the suffering is turned
to absolute good for others, no matter how bad it is, there's a survival in it.
On the other hand, if you think of how to let everything which you may suffer flow in my will,
there will be no clouds for you. And the very pains will bring you light. In other words,
your understanding is deepened and so on. It's wonderful. And it will open new currents of union,
love and grace. Now, there's something you need to underline. Because Jesus is saying,
if we have the wisdom and the love to unite anything that causes us pain and suffering and
struggle, to unite with the sufferings and pains and struggles of Jesus's life and in the divine
will and offer them to save souls from falling into hell. He said, "It will open new levels of
divine union between himself and you." In other words, you will grow in union with God.
And there will be tremendous grace attached to that. That's a very important message.
In fact, there'll be VIPs on most of the stuff because as we go on into volume 12,
every single bit of it are jewels, you know. So August the 12th, 1916, the glory of the souls
who will live in the divine will on earth. So really watch this one. So we have the privilege
of living in the divine will on earth. And Jesus is talking about the glory of those souls, okay?
So Louisa said, "I was fusing myself in the most holy will, and my sweet Jesus said, my daughter,
only one who lives in my will. Do I fail as though repaid for creation, redemption, and sanctification?"
That's the three fiots. Notice he says, repaid. And yet we're absolute. Nothing's.
That's the incredible thing. But at least he's getting a response.
You know yourself as a parent that if a child responds positively and lovingly to something
you try to do for you feel repaid, don't you? That they can't pay you in money. That's not
the issue. Money is actually nothing. To be repaid in love and gratitude is the joy of a parent,
isn't it? And makes you feel it was all worthwhile even though there was great trouble involved in
it. So that's what Jesus is saying, that to respond in love and gratitude and in the divine will to
him, as far as he's concerned, he's repaid for his trouble. Therefore, these souls will be the
gems of my throne. And we have to balance this extraordinary thing that on the one hand of
ourselves were absolute nothings. And on the other hand, then were gems on his throne. Isn't
it amazing? Therefore, these souls will be the gems of my throne and will take within themselves
all contentment. Notice the word "all" and the glory which each blessed will have for himself alone.
They will be able to take within themselves all the contentment and the glory which each
blessed will have for himself alone. You can actually reach out for it all. These souls will be as though
queens around my throne and all the blessed will be around them. Now notice the queens. That reference
there is to the song of songs and you have the chosen bride and you've got all these other queens.
Now in heaven the chosen bride of course is blessed mother and then we are her maiden companions, the
other queens. These souls will be as though queens around my throne and all the blessed will be around
them because they didn't have the privilege of living the divine will on earth. And just as the
blessed will be as many suns that will shine in the celestial Jerusalem, the souls who have lived
in my will will shine in my own sun. Now notice there are sun and suns. Now the celestial Jerusalem
is Revelation 21-22 and if you go to Revelation 21 you'll be told that the dwellers in this new
Jerusalem needed no sunlight because Jesus was the sun. Okay so here you have this image of all the
dwellers in the new Jerusalem. Jesus is the sun for them but the people who have lived in his will
are actually in the sun. Is that something else? He said they will shine in my own sun. They will
be as though circumfused with my sun and these souls will see the blessed from within me. Talk
about privileged positions. It's absolutely amazing because it is right that having lived on earth
united with me with my will. Now notice it's with my will. Okay as they have lived no life of their
own because we've given up the human will for the divine. They have a distinct place from all the
others in heaven. Now he comes back to this point many many times as we go from here to the 36
volumes. They have a distinct place in heaven and they continue in heaven the life that they have
lived on earth. In other words you continue living in the divine will. Completely transformed in me
so therefore other Christ and immersed in the sea of my contentment.
I think that's not a bad reward. Okay so how about putting heading their reward at the top?
Because human beings aren't trying to say well you know is there anything at the other end of the
line? Is it all give give give? Now I'm going to stop there for a few minutes.